-Performing her new song,
"What a Lie,"
here's Justine Skye!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I left all the doors
unlocked ♪
♪ And you said
you're on your way ♪
♪ When you get here
don't you say a word ♪
♪ Got no time to play ♪
♪ I know you think
that you know me ♪
♪ But you ain't even see
my dark side ♪
-♪ Dark side ♪
♪♪
-♪ User, what a user ♪
♪ A blessing, learning lessons ♪
♪ A season for entertaining
leeches ♪
♪ My poison was your peaches ♪
♪ Could've saved my time,
should've taken my space ♪
♪ That's what needed
my attention ♪
♪ Not your stupid face ♪
♪ Wish I read between the lines,
you were readin' me ♪
♪ Such an actor, what you were
after was the industry ♪
♪ Couldn't believe I caught you
that night ♪
♪ Saw the messages
in plain sight ♪
♪ How you never thought
to delete ♪
♪ Like you wanted me
to read them now ♪
♪ And it blows my mind ♪
♪ Happened overnight ♪
♪ What a lie, I fell for
this time, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ User, what a loser ♪
♪ No one will ever know
how much I put you on ♪
♪ All they'll ever know
is how you a sing a song ♪
♪ But what kind of a man makes
you part of his marketing plan ♪
♪ Ew, ugh ♪
♪ Couldn't believe I caught you
that night ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Saw the messages
in plain sight ♪
♪ How you never thought
to delete ♪
♪ Like you wanted me
to read them now ♪
♪ And it blows my mind ♪
♪ Happened overnight ♪
♪ What a lie, I fell for
this time, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ And it blows my mind ♪
♪ Happened overnight ♪
♪ What a lie, I fell for
this time, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Finally moved on ♪
♪ My love, you lost ♪
♪ You mad, so sad ♪
♪ Forget you, I'm gone ♪
♪ I'll be away, it's a new day ♪
♪ Get out my way ♪
♪ Can't talk, go away ♪
♪ Look at my view ♪
♪ With someone new ♪
♪ All that I do ♪
♪ Is without you ♪
♪ Is without you,
is without you ♪
is without... ♪
-♪ Oh ♪
-♪ Without you ♪
-♪ Without you, ooh, ooh ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ♪
♪♪
♪ And it blows my mind ♪
♪ Happened overnight ♪
-♪ What a lie ♪
♪ I fell for this time,
ooh, ooh ♪
[ Guitar solo ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]